Okwe Juanita suck
Cassie Leonard nor'easter walk hello
good day everyone I'm from the
Shinnecock nation taboo 'tony to the
Kuya peoples whose land we gather on
today I was taught that water is alive
it can hear it holds memories and so I
brought a water vessel up with me today
because I want it to hold the memories
of our conversation today who gets legal
rights history has shown us some people
but not others in the United States
indigenous peoples like myself were not
citizens under the law until 1924 my
Shinnecock ancestors pictured here were
not citizens under the law then why do
we claim to be nations governed by the
rule of law if some people are protected
but not others because it remains one of
the best ways to fight injustice has
indigenous people we know injustice a
dear friend mentor water Walker no kumis
grandmother josephine manaman bach she
told me of a prophecy that comes from
her people the Anishinabe of the
madeleine society and in that prophecy
she told me that it tells of a day that
will come where an ounce of water costs
more than an ounce of gold when she told
me that process II I stopped for a
moment and I thought about all of the
injustice 'as we see in our world today
the water crises we see in our world
today and I said no commence grandmother
I feel like we are already in that time
of prophecy and she looked back at me
directly and she said so what are you
going to do about it that's why I'm here
with you today because I believe that
one of the many solutions to solving the
many water injustice as we see in our
world today is recognizing that water is
a living relation and granting it the
legal personhood it deserves so to do so
we need to transform the way in which we
value water we have to start to think
about how do we connect to water usually
someone might ask you what is water and
you would respond with rain ocean lake
river h2o liquid you might even
understand the sacred essentiality of
water and say that water is life but
what if I asked you instead who is water
in the same way that I might ask you who
is your grandmother who is your sister
that type of orientation fundamentally
transforms the way in which we think
about water transforms the way in which
we make decisions about how we might
protect water protect it in the way that
you would protect your grandmother your
mother your sister your aunties that is
the type of transformation that we need
if we are going to address the many
water crises we see in our world today
these harrowing water crises that have
streamed across our digital devices in
countdowns today zero the point at which
municipal water supplies are shut off
places like Cape Town South Africa where
in 2018 residents were limited to two
minute showers and 23 gallons of water
per day per person or just this past
summer where the mismanagement of water
led the streets of Chennai to be lined
with thousands of plastic water jugs as
residents waited hours for water tankers
to deliver water first by rail than by
truck to meet their daily needs or even
here in the United States one of the
most developed nations in the world
today Flint Michigan still does not have
clean water but you are likely on
familiar with these water crises such as
mich gonzaga first nation in northern
ontario canada where residents have been
on a boil water advisory since 1995 or
grassy narrows first nation which for
decades has been dealing with water
contamination from the paper mill
industry and where a recent study found
that nearly 90 percent of the indigenous
population has some form of mercury
poisoning causing severe health
complications or even among the Navajo
Nation pictured here is the Animas River
on an early morning in 2015
prior to the gold King mine spill after
the spill leaked millions of hazardous
mine waste into the river system this
was it later that day today the Navajo
Nation and the Dannette people and the
river itself are still trying to recover
from contamination or even right here in
Palm Springs California where the agua
caliente band of Cahuilla Indians has
been fighting for decades to protect
groundwater from exploitation so that
future generations can not only live but
thrive in their homelands as they have
since time immemorial you see a recent
study by dig deep and the u.s. water
Alliance found that race in the United
States is a strongest predictor of water
and sanitation access and not for us as
Native American people we are the group
most likely to have access issues as it
comes to water and sanitation so as an
indigenous legal scholar and scientists
I believe that many of these water and
justices are the result of the Western
legal systems failure to recognize the
legal personhood of water and so we must
ask ourselves who is justice for
humanity alone we've granted legal
personhood to corporations in the u.s.
the Supreme Court found and citizens
united that a corporation was a person
with similar protections under the
Constitution such as freedom of speech
and applied similar reasoning and Hobby
Lobby finding that a corporation had the
right to freedom of religion and defense
against implement
of the Affordable Care Act for its
employees now these are controversial
cases and as a Shinnecock woman and a
legal scholar they make me question the
moral compass of the Western world where
you can grant legal personhood to a
corporation but not nature you see legal
personhood grants us the ability to be
visible in a court of law and to have
our voices heard as a person protected
under the law and so if you can grant
that to a corporation why not the Great
Lakes why not the Mississippi River why
not the many waterways across our planet
that we all depend on to survive we know
we are in a global climate crisis
but globally our waters are also
threatened and we are facing a global
water crisis and if we want to address
these crises in our lifetime we need to
change we need to fundamentally
transform the way in which we value
water and this is not something new for
us as indigenous peoples our indigenous
legal systems have a foundational
principle of understanding our non human
relations as being living and protected
under our laws and even for the Western
world environmental legal theorists have
argued for the rights of nature since
the 1970s but we need to do better we
need to change and we need to grant
legal personhood to water because it
affords the following rights and
protections it grants water the right to
exist flourish and naturally evolve and
most of all it protects water from us
from human beings that would do it harm
from human caused climate change impacts
from pollutants and from man-made
contamination moreover it reverses the
accepted hierarchy of humanity's
domination over nature as human beings
on this planet we are not superior to
other beings on this planet we are not
superior to the
water itself we have to learn how to be
good stewards again we often imagine
that the world is filled with infinite
water in fact it's not this planet okey
Mother Earth has very finite freshwater
resources currently nearly two billion
people live in countries experiencing
high water stress it is also estimated
that by 2030 up to 700 million people
could be displaced worldwide due to
water scarcity we have to address this
crisis and so it's time for us to change
we have to transform the way in which we
value water and we can do that we can
learn to be good stewards again we can
create laws through which we grant legal
personhood to water we can start to
honor the original treaties between
indigenous peoples and non-indigenous
peoples for water protection we can
appoint guardians for the water that
ensure the waters rights are always
protected we can also develop water
quality standards that have a holistic
approach that ensure the well-being of
the water before our human needs and
moreover we can work to dismantle
exclusive property ownership over water
and there are amazing successful
examples of this around the world the
fungal new weed Riveter and Al Toyota
roll in New Zealand and the Ganges River
in India were both granted legal
personhood in 2017 and even this year
the residents of the city of Toledo
recognized the legal personality of Lake
Erie and right here in California the
Yurok tribe granted legal personhood to
the Klamath River
you see I imagine a world where we value
water as a living relation where we work
to restore our connection to water as
women we are water carriers we nurture
water in our wombs for nine months it's
the first medicine that each of us as
human beings is exposed to see we are
all born
human beings with a natal connection to
water but somewhere along the way we
lost that connection and we have to work
to restore it because I imagine a world
in which water is healthy and ecosystems
are thriving I imagine a world where
each of us takes up our right of
responsibility as water citizens and
protects water
so in the words of no kumis what are you
going to do about it what are you going
to do for the water well you can call
your local politician you can go to a
town meeting you can advocate for
granting legal personhood to water you
can be like the residents of the city of
Toledo and build from the grassroots and
craft your own legislation if the
politicians won't write it recognising
legal personality of water you can learn
about the indigenous lands and waters
that you now occupy and the indigenous
legal systems that still govern them and
most of all you can connect to water you
can restore that connection go to the
water closest to your home and find out
why it is threatened but most of all if
you do anything I ask that you make a
promise to yourself that each day you
will ask what have I done for the water
today if we are able to fulfill that
promise I believe we can create a bold
and brilliant world where future
generations are able to form the same
relationship to water that we have been
privileged to have where all communities
of human and non-human relations have
water to live because water is life Tabu
'tony thank you
[Applause]
[Music]